welcome everyone thank you for joining
us for today's keynote presentation
considering cannabis is a traditional
crop it is presented by Chia physio PhD
an independent consultant supporting the
agricultural biotechnology industry my
name is Judy O'Rourke and I'll be your
moderator for today's event
we're delighted to bring you this
educational web seminar presented by
laberd's laggards is the leading
scientific social networking website and
producer of educational virtual events
and webinars before we begin I would
like to remind everyone that this event
is interactive we encourage you to
participate by submitting as many
questions as you want during the
presentation simply click on the ask a
question box located on the far left of
your screen and type your questions into
the drop down box our speaker will
respond to your questions via email
following the presentation if you have
trouble seeing or hearing the
presentation please click on the ask a
question box to let us know that you're
experiencing a problem this presentation
is educational and thus offers
continuing education credits please
click on the continuing education
credits tab located in the top right
corner of the presentation window and
follow the process to obtain your
credits and now without further ado
please join me in welcoming dr. Fazzio
I will now turn the presentation over to
her thank you Judy for that introduction
and hello everyone thank you for being
here and listening to my presentation as
Judy mentioned I'm coming from the
agricultural biotechnology industry and
so I'm thinking about cannabis and a
perhaps different light then some people
might be thinking about it today and so
I just kind of wanted to provide an
overview of a new perspective on
thinking about cannabis in that
perspective so just a brief overview of
my presentation first I'd like to talk
about the cannabis industry both in
terms of a market and also its
exponential growth so that it's
currently experiencing and then move
into the agronomy of cannabis how is it
being grown currently
and what are the regulations associated
with that grants process and then I'll
move into key market initiatives related
to plant health and and regulations and
also the marketability of those products
so how how currently is the cannabis
industry looking at the opportunities
and a different life than they have been
in the past and then wrap up with some
potential areas of improvement kind of
my perspective and my spin on you know
what better are there better ways that
we can be producing this this plant and
what are some new opportunities that
would consider as we go forward so the
cannabis industry no one would argue I
believe that it is experiencing
absolutely exponential growth in the
United States and what's really
interesting about it however is the
various stakeholders that are involved
so if you think about the agricultural
biotechnology industry you see some very
traditional investors looking at perhaps
investing at a farming level or perhaps
that a seed production level and seed
identity preservation with the cannabis
industry it's a little bit different so
you have those traditional investors who
are looking up and down the value chain
but there are also some investors who
are not necessarily thinking about it in
terms of they don't really want to be
associated with perhaps the aspect of
conception they want to be a little bit
further away from that and look at
perhaps the testing or extraction and
the marketing and and be a little bit
distant from the consumption part of it
and we'll talk about why that is
throughout the talk so also you know the
regulations currently are state by state
and so that's both a an opportunity and
a challenge it's a challenge and that
you know there's some limit on those
multi-unit businesses that are or
farming opportunities that are limiting
that growth potential but on the flip
side of that there's a lot of
legalization and decriminalization
associated with with cannabis both for
medicinal and recreational use and so
that's spurring a lot of
grunts and then as I mentioned at the
farmer and operator level the people who
are actually growing the plants that
permitting process is currently no
matter what state you're looking at it's
it's fairly tightly regulated and as a
consequence you're seeing a lot of
people becoming either permit experts or
multi unit experts who are printer their
primary permit holders within their
state and opening up multiple businesses
within their region and then some new
avenues where there has been some recent
investment and you know looking at the
cannabis headlines these days and
actually not just related to cannabis
but agriculture in general a new avenues
oil health's and I think from an from my
agricultural background this is a really
great opportunity and and so I'm so glad
to see this being an area that cannabis
growers and and investors are looking at
because I believe there's a lot of
research that can you know it's just
beginning there's a lot of research that
can still continue and that are provided
enormous benefits not just to the
cannabis industry alone but to
agriculture in general and then you know
there's this investment in rootstocks
and identity preservation you know if
you think about wineries they have been
doing this for decades and you know and
also and fruit and spend stone fruit
trees as well and so we're seeing kind
of what might not be necessarily
traditional for what I'm thinking of
cannabis as a simple plant but looking
at that root stock and how that can be
improved and that will bring also a
number of benefits to agricultural
biotechnology in general as well and
then the cultivation practices and so
I'll talk about this a little bit later
but you know it's a little bit perhaps
premature and immature in the cannabis
industry whereas the agricultural bio
industry is going to bring a lot of
ideas and process to the cannabis market
so to talk a little bit about that that
market so the CAG are projections in
2017 it was an 8.5
in dollar industry and its projected to
grow up to 40 billion dollars by 2023
and when I looked at this just a year
ago the same report a year ago the
annual growth rate was actually only
around 20 to 25 percent and so even in
the last year you know we were talking
about that exponential growth a little
bit ago I mean even last year it's it's
already increased by 10 percent the
projected annual growth and of course we
know that's coming from both the
medicinal and recreational legalization
across multiple states but also like we
were talking about before the
decriminalization so what are those
market impacts that we can expect as we
go forward well as I said you know it's
regulated state by state and many of you
probably already know that but you know
because cannabis for the THC concept
content it's still considered a class 1
drug and so there are a lot of federal
roadblocks that are associated with the
expansion of this market whatever on a
casa con or bats there's been a
decriminalization and so there was a the
Attorney General Deputy Attorney General
James Cole put forth the memorandum
during the last administration that D
prioritized that criminalization aspect
and looked at perhaps either not being
as punitive or eliminating the
restrictions altogether
however and during the current
ministration that was rescinded and with
the acknowledgement that the states
still have complete control and it's
regulated at the state level and that we
need to look forward at the federal
policy and I believe that this will
continue to be a challenge and something
to be investigated further as we as the
cannabis industry continues to grow
perhaps not in the next five years
certainly because the growth that we're
experiencing is independent of any
regulations at this point are federal
regulations at this point but it is kind
of a roadblock that will need to be
considered long term and then a
kind of perhaps not a surprise there's
going to be enormous amounts of
competition there already is you know I
talked about the the permit holders are
mostly restricted to a handful of people
like those permits are very difficult
and to obtain both from a farming
perspective as well as a dispensing
permitting process and so you know
you're seeing a surge in people who are
becoming experts and the kind of the go
tools for those processes and then yeah
so thinking about security and handling
of the product again it's still a
classic stone drug so it's it's it's an
issue for producers to manage their
product I actually have a colleague
who's working in the industry directly
with a with a direct market producer and
they're the throughput is so this is
coming through it's such a speed that
they're challenged with things that
might be less familiar to perhaps a
market that's more mature so if you have
an immature market like the cannabis
industry they're not used to dealing
with high throughput high demand multi
you know high high units of business
whereas they're already seeing that it's
kind of they're literally putting the
cart before the horse where there are
there's such a high demand that they're
almost just trying to get it out the
door as fast as they can and they're
being challenged with some of those
production opportunities handling you
know the handoff between different parts
of the value chain and so this is
something that will need to be continued
to be cleaned up as the cannabis
industry continues to grow in another
area that's spurring that girls are
multiple areas that are screwing that
growth um if you think about it just
simple real estate and construction
opportunities so now you have these
dispensaries popping up throughout
multiple states where it's become
legalized and so there there's creating
a huge job market both from not just for
real estates but also for the employment
of those
people who might be billing out those
those stores or the greenhouses or the
warehouses that are providing the
material and while the primary part of
the majority of the of the market if you
will is still focused on either smoking
or meat being the cannabis leaf product
and bud product there has been this
surge of interest into the extract of
oil from the cannabis plant as well and
so this is being incorporated in
multiple ways which we'll talk about the
next slide but that of course is
providing a lot of that forty billion
dollar anticipated growth and then of
course the revenue projected is to be an
enormous number so it's it's what's
really great about all of these numbers
is the investment and interest in the
cannabis industry and so if you think
about cannabis is simply a plant it's
going to provide a lot of opportunity
going forward so you know I here I am
talking about how cannabis is like great
and wonderful and everything but really
it's a plant that's been around for
thousands of years it's its latin name
roughly translates to fragrant cane and
that's coming from those those chirping
products so THC and CBD and other
metabolites of the plant are actually
coming from terpenes so the same thing
that makes oranges smell like a nice
orange or a lemon that smells that gives
that characteristic lemon smell those
are all metabolites of terpenoids and so
not surprisingly that's how it's got its
name we're all familiar with the
medicinal and recreational uses however
now that they are more research they're
finding other opportunities both in
textiles and paper products and lotions
for various anti-inflammatory or skin
conditions but perhaps something that we
don't think about very often are the
potential opportunities for both as a
feedstock right that's still a plant it
produces a protein that can be very
useful to livestock then also it's a
fibrous plant after you extract
what you might want the the leaves the
buds the oil there's still quite a bit
of fiber left and there are going to be
lots of applications looked at for
opportunities to use use it use the
plant completely so like I said before
cannabis really is just a plant so let's
compare it to feed and and row crops
well those perhaps four require light
water and nutrients so does cannabis
plants are sessile organisms and so is
cannabis so this isn't you know in the
agricultural biotechnology industry
there is interest in research and
perhaps up regulating a certain gene or
breeding to bring out a desired quality
in that plant you know eventually the
plant is going to balance itself out and
because it can't move I can't get up and
go get more water and it can't get up
and go get more nitrogen that it's going
to need to grow so because there's going
to be such an investment in
understanding cannabis as a whole this
is going to turn in turn support the
feed and grow crop industry traditional
crops are to require about up to 120
days to maturity and cannabis falls
right within that within that bandwidth
as well and not surprisingly the broad
crop industry is focused really
primarily on yield and composition so
how much can we get per acre and what is
the composition is it is it the most
protein is it the most oil is it the
best quality oil that we can yield and
cannabis is not too dissimilar right so
we're looking at how much what is the
maximum production that we can get from
the plant not only from a you know total
aerial part of the plant yield but also
what is the composition are we looking
to get more CBD for anti-inflammatory
applications are we looking for more THC
to help with other medicinal
applications or recreational uses that
people might be searching for and
however this is where things start to
differ so the traditional AG biotech
industry has been focused on not just
yield and composition but also
performance how's the plant doing in
different environments is it able to be
grown across multiple growing regions
both in the north and the southern part
of the US
what is its tolerance to different
insect pressures or or none or abiotic
dressers lack of water decreased
nutrients and what are the costs of
those inputs and and also anybody who's
familiar with agriculture will know that
there's a huge issue around identity
preservation you know those seeds are
very important commodities to the seed
producers who are are generating those
plants and of course then there's been a
huge investment in making sure that's
maintained and held and provides an
advantage over perhaps competitors the
cannabis industry while there's
investment and interest in it and there
are some really good breeders who are
you know have their specific lines this
investigation and interest and
investment in understanding what the
plants tolerance is or how much does it
actually cost to grow a certain amount
of product is really lacking and so this
is another area of where I believe the
agricultural biotech industry will be
able to benefit the cannabis industry
and of course the regulations are very
well defined on the real crop side and
federally and regulated at the federal
level for the most part too much to get
into too much detail to get into at this
point in this in this talk here but as
we were talking about earlier with this
complete disassociation of the federal
government at the state level you know
as the cannabis market continues to
expand and grow and develop and and
reach into other other states this is
going to be an area that the federal
government will really need to take a
hard look at and think about how we're
regulating the product so just taking a
step back on the a little bit more
detail on how is cannabis grown you know
germination takes about a week see
about two weeks vegetative growth is
anywhere from two to eight weeks
depending on what the day length is for
those plants and then of course the ever
important flowering process up until
recently that's really been the primary
objective of growers is to obtain really
nice healthy flower buds because that
contains the most product of interest
where cannabis differs from other crops
is this curing process and that can take
anywhere from two to eight weeks so
that's slowly drying plant down to get
it to a point that it's not too dry but
just the right point of harvest and you
don't necessarily see that with other
row crops you see that with rice and
wheat they could go through a drying
process but something like corn soybean
it lessa
the farmer might not want rain or water
his or her fields for a few days prior
to harvest but primarily that curing
process is very unique to cannabis the
equipment required for for growth like I
was talking about earlier it's some sort
of nutrient delivery primarily the girls
has been in warehouses and in
greenhouses and so it's it's been a
little bit on under the radar but as
that is becoming less of an issue we're
seeing some investment in a very precise
amount of nutrients being delivered to
each plant and then of course there are
sensors enormous amounts of sensors both
things that you see in the traditional
industry like you know sensors that you
actually put at the level of the soil
and also drone drones that fly over to
observe girls and monitor the progress
in the case of when supplemental
lighting is needed it used to be in the
industry and the cannabis industry that
LEDs were used and this was mostly to
remain under the radar and not use a
large amount of electricity to power
those but you see the industry switching
to high pressure sodium this is an exact
opposite of what you're seeing in
agriculture LEDs have become an enormous
the more diverse in the last few years
using different lenses and filters and
so now you're seeing a shift and
biotech industry moving away from high
pressure sodium switch require an
enormous amount of energy and put out a
lot of heat to LEDs so well I guess
we'll figure out which one is the most
beneficial to to plants in general and
then farmers are managing at least from
a field ground perspective they're
managing cannabis similar to to eat
weeds of grass so it's mostly gonna grow
vertical but cannabis is not a dress
it's die cut so it's gonna grow a little
bit more out but from a harvest
perspective farmers are able to make
slight adaptations to their combine and
go through the field and harvest it
similarly to meat and then on the on the
final harvest side like I was talking
about earlier those they're bailing
these fiber stocks so what's left after
harvesting the flowers and the leaves
they have found that it's quite stable
for a couple of years and while they're
not might not be a use for those fiber
stocks today they're going they're
wrapping them and storing them for hope
that you know even in the next couple of
years that there will be a use and use
for those those products and so from a
farming perspective you know this is
pretty early in the end the value chain
farmers are seeing a benefit of 250 to
350 dollars per acre so to give you a
counterbalance to that farmers sometimes
at least on the operating side it can
vary quite a lot between two hundred you
know around two hundred dollars just
three hundred and some odd dollars per
acre but that's variable and they're you
know they're actual profit per acre is
more but in the seven to eight hundred
dollar range but they're having to pay
the seed companies they're having to pay
the grain elevators and they're having
to you know end up paying a lot more out
of their own pocket not necessarily I
don't excuse me ain't not out of their
own pocket but their end up having to
pay a lot more a lot more money as going
through their hands and not necessarily
staying with them and so there's this
incentive maybe to be a little bit more
in control they're not paying a seed
company for the cannabis seeds
and they're not necessarily paying a
grain elevator they're providing that
directly to someone who's either gonna
extract it or market it directly to the
consumer as a counterbalance though no
insurance companies no farming insurance
companies are offering insurance to
farmers and this is a huge risk for them
you know farmers either whether the
commodity prices are down or they're
experiencing a an unusual weather issue
like hail or a late snow or early Frost
if you're growing cannabis there's no
protection there so it is a little bit
of a risk and then of course there are
additional fees associated with that
what's growing cannabis again going back
to that permitting process is definitely
a challenge looking at it from a just a
simple greenhouse slash indoor growth
process there's a there's a direct
tiered investment so if you're going to
provide a small amount of input from
climate control and you know nutrient
input watering and maintenance you're
going to get low yields but
interestingly when you provide higher
quality light better nutrients more
consistent care and growing conditions
you not only do you get higher yields
but you're able to fetch a little bit of
a higher price because your overall
production is much higher and so I'm
gonna talk about that a little bit more
so looking at the differences between
outdoor and indoor growth this is
flipping what you see mostly an
agronomic performance when you're
growing plants in a greenhouse you have
a lot of control over you know the
sunlight the or supplemental light and
also the watering and inputs but
generally yield is not necessarily
better indoors
whereas currently in cannabis they are
seeing a strong benefit and indoor
yields and so this goes back to the
issue of cannabis hasn't been cultivated
to be able to grow outside it doesn't
have a high natural insect pressure
tolerance and it doesn't really
appreciate going without water for a
couple of days if a farmer's field is
being rain-fed
so when thinking about how the industry
is going to continue to develop the the
cost of growing outside of course is low
over all right you're not having to
provide a supplemental light but you're
having to adapt the equipment and you're
gonna going to experience lower yields
versus if you're going to grow indoors
you're going to see a better yield but
you're also gonna have to put a little
bit more money investment into the plant
and so again just thinking about it and
the long-term perspective a farmer who
might want to be converting you know
looking at that $350 price tag of profit
is going to have to weigh these things
and going to be turning to the seed
producers and saying hey I need a better
quality seed so I can grow this outside
and convert my wheat field
to a cannabis field so with all that
negativity being said the industry is
definitely improving
we're seeing a lot more investment in
those processes like I was talking about
earlier with the root stocks that's a
it's a key opportunity for people who
are perhaps moving out of the AG biotech
industry and wanting to move into canvas
for one reason or another switching jobs
or moving for whatever reason there's a
definite opportunity to look at those
different ways to improve the plant and
then of course looking at the capital
fundraising you know right now it's been
primarily at the at the marketing level
at the consumer level and we're going to
see a lot of vertical integration of
that process not just from the seat just
looking at the seed and also the product
but a lot of stuff in between you know
how can we improve the product how can
we provide you know our a higher level
of CBD for whatever application that a
consumer might be looking for and then
using transferring a lot of those AG
biotech that knowledgebase from a
breeding perspective a Dometic
engineering perspective a gene editing
perspective and also the using drones
and adapt
drones and building algorithms to you
know improve growth and and and perhaps
also control a little bit more of that
of that security of someone's product
and then you know anybody who has ever
been involved in retail knows that it's
all about the consumer and so we'll see
an improvement in the retail experience
as well if you've ever gone into a shop
you know it's it's it's a whole new
experience it's like it's like getting
to going to almost like a you know an
infinite amount of choices and so we'll
continue to see that improve with a
fundamental understanding of what the
plan is providing so where can we
provide where where can we do a little
bit better investigation what are the
areas that we can improve the plants and
and and the whole industry in general
there are some certainly a handful of
companies who are doing a very good job
doing some fundraising initiatives on
some of these issues but just to kind of
give an overview of what the
opportunities are I was talking about
soil health earlier that's really
dependent on on microbial population so
there are natural bacteria and yeast
that exist in the soil today we're only
beginning to understand how they
interact with plants and tree up
nutrients to make them more bioavailable
to the plant and also provide better
disease and pest resistance naturally
that's also an area where many companies
in the AG biotech industry are investing
an enormous amount of research and
understanding but really you're not
necessarily seeing that expansion yet
into the cannabis industry and what will
be interesting is we're learning that
biotech side is that actually has an
impact on not just the plant health and
itself but also how is it you know how
does it change
the plant branching as it matures does
it change its flowering time can we
avoid that potential early frost and can
we improve the oil composition if we
wanted to produce a plant that had
higher THC or CBD or some other
turpenoid of interest that we don't know
is key to
helping a medical need today but we
might know it two years from now you
know is there a microbe that can help
impact and impart that oil composition
benefit again traditional breeding does
a very good job and biotech side of
improving different varieties to help
with disease resistance I won't be
surprised when we come out with our
first genetically engineered or
genetically improved cannabis plant to
help with drought and make that input
cost lower adapt the plant to be able to
grow better outside and be a little bit
more Hardy and then a challenge with the
cannabis industry is that some people
just frankly don't care for the taste or
the that sensory those terpenes are a
little bit aggravating or unsavory for
them and so that's also an oil so it's
going to have a limited shelf life it's
to some extent so how can we improve
that in the plant at the plant level and
then you know that that state state
limitation that will obviously change
the industry going forward and and how
we how the United States and interacts
with the rest of the world which you
know of course there's varying levels of
acceptance outside the US borders so
it'll be interesting to see how that
continues to expand going forward and
then you know there there are primary
seed biotech and biotech industries
companies and and right now the cannabis
industry is quite fractionated um you
know there are certainly growers who
like their particular varieties and have
really unique names how are we going to
continue to preserve those and and
maintain those those lines going forward
will we need to incorporate genetic
markers will there be metabolic
fingerprints that are unique to each
plant that will be kind of the signature
of the cannabis industry and so just
thinking about that in a different a
little bit more of an expansion so
there is a current an interest in
understanding how you know what is the
formulation what does that magic
formulation of the plants and how can it
be be maximized so for some people it's
like the duration of the relief of
whatever it is that they're looking for
whether it's a that's for recreational
use or whether it's for medicinal use
from a social anxiety perspective or
other issues that people are finding a
use for cannabis you know how can we
make that plant have a higher not just a
higher yield but make it more available
to the consumer as well and then also
looking at it from an efficiency
perspective you know is there a way to
extract it more efficiently more
efficiently at a lower cost and get it
to the to the consumer more quickly you
know you're thinking about that process
where the Third Point is so fast right
now that they're actually gonna be
challenged going forward to meet the
demand and so our that are ways of
improving the plant to market process so
that it is an easier and more a more
speedy process and again thinking about
the plant from my tolerance perspective
are there opportunities to integrate
what we know from the AG biotech
industry today with regard to pest
tolerance abiotic stress tolerance that
we can either breed into the plants from
a variety you know different varieties
that exist or maybe more heirloom
varieties of the plants that were a
little bit perhaps less desirable from a
from a palatability perspective or yield
perspective but are a little bit more
hearty and can be grown outside and then
you know there are a lot of really good
libraries publicly available for a
variety of crops through the USDA and it
wouldn't be again a huge surprise if we
start to see that with cannabis as well
as investors become more interested in
improving the products it's really great
to open up the research field and and
provide new opportunities for research
and investment for to either
develop libraries or improve composition
and again do genetic engineering so in
summary you know I think of cannabis an
agronomic perspective it's a two-way
street
um the industry is is is huge and
enormous and there's a lot of investment
in it and they're doing a lot of really
interesting things but on the flip side
I think what all of the investment that
will be going into cannabis will
ultimately benefit the AG biotech
industry as well we're going to learn a
lot about plants that's gonna be in an
accelerated rate and what's really great
about it is that there's a lot of money
in there whereas you know there there's
you know a biotech interest industry
it's not as as appealing and not as eye
catching as the cannabis industry is so
it'll be really good to draw in those
investors who might not have been as
interested in AG biotech but are
interested in cannabis drawn some extra
money to to improve research and improve
the products you know we talked a little
bit about the cultivation practices and
how its managed today and certainly will
continue to see an improvement in there
if we're going to reap the benefits of
being able to grow the plant outside and
use natural inputs to provide the best
yield of those plants with the caveat
that there needs to be a better balance
of regulations created that it's really
strict at the at the plant growth level
but perhaps at the up and down value
chain that needs to be it needs to be
addressed and then as we continue to
learn more will harmonize the way that
we're managing those cannabis plants and
production and ultimately the products
themselves through either identity
permanent preservation or library
development so that ultimately we're
providing the best product to consumers
and my last slide is just some
references for the different parts that
I talked about today and that's all I
have please send me your questions I am
open to questions challenges and other
things that you might want to talk about
thank you
Thank You dr. Fazzio for that
informative presentation I would also
like to thank lab roots for making
today's educational webcast possible as
a reminder our speaker will follow up
with any questions you've submitted via
email that is all for now thank you for
joining us we'll see you next time
goodbye